lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es que
pensemos en qué significa el tener el
opuesto de un número y lo primero que
vamos a hacer es dibujar una recta
numérica tenemos por aquí una recta
numérica
y podemos empezar por aquí con el celo y
si nos vamos a la derecha tenemos puros
números positivos vamos a empezar con el
1 después 2
4 y 5 pero si nos vamos a la izquierda
del 0 tenemos puros números negativos
ok tenemos menos 1 - 2 - 3
-4 y podríamos seguir así un buen rato
bueno pero ahora escojamos un número
porque no escogemos por ejemplo el
número 3 cual es el opuesto del número 3
pues el opuesto es el número que está a
la misma distancia del 0 pero del otro
lado aunque para llegar al 3 nos tenemos
que mover 1 2 3 lugares hacia la derecha
del 0 entonces para llegar al opuesto de
3 nos tenemos que mover 3 lugares hacia
el otro lado aunque nos tenemos que
mover 1 2 3 lugares hacia el otro lado
así es que menos 3 es el opuesto de 3 y
vamos a hacer una tabla por aquí con los
números y sus supuestos tenemos por aquí
los números
números y por aquí vamos a poner sus
opuestos
pues todos
ok teníamos aquí al número 3
- 3 - 3 es el opuesto del 3 ahora qué
sucede si el número es un número
negativo aunque ay qué pasa si por
ejemplo queremos saber cuál es el número
opuesto de menos 4 y aquí te recomiendo
que lo pongas una pausa al vídeo y
trates de encontrar la respuesta por tu
cuenta
bueno pues el -4 está por aquí de este
lado del 0 y partiendo del 0 tenemos que
movernos 1 2 3 4 lugares hacia la
izquierda para llegar al menos 4
entonces el opuesto del -4 tiene que ser
4 lugares hacia la derecha aunque 1 2
4 y listo el 4 es el opuesto del -4 no
creer que es un número positivo muy
parecido a este propositivo y
seguramente aquí te estás dando cuenta
de un patrón que podemos observar aquí y
eso es que los números opuestos son casi
iguales pero tienen el signo opuesto y
son casi iguales su valor absoluto es el
mismo pero tienen signos distintos si
tenemos un 3 positivo que sería como
tener un + 3 pero nunca ponemos el
símbolo de me das el opuesto es menos 3
y si tenemos menos 4 el opuesto es
simplemente 4 así es que hay dos formas
de pensar en esto por un lado podemos
pensar en que el valor absoluto del
número es el mismo pero que cambiamos el
signo si no tenemos ningún signo
entonces ponemos un signo de menos
o si tenemos un menos entonces quitamos
ese menos o la otra forma es pensar que
si tenemos que saltar tres lugares a la
derecha para obtener este número
entonces para llegar al opuesto tenemos
que saltar tres lugares hacia la
izquierda y al revés si empezamos
saltando cuatro lugares hacia la
izquierda
entonces para obtener el opuesto tenemos
que saltar cuatro lugares hacia la
derecha pero bueno hagamos un último
ejemplo digamos por ejemplo que tenemos
el número uno el uno se encuentra por
aquí y para llegar del 0 al 1 tenemos
que saltar un paso hacia la derecha así
es que el opuesto del 1 lo obtenemos
saltando un paso hacia la izquierda así
es que este es el opuesto de uno menos
uno o podemos pensarlo de la otra forma
aunque el opuesto de uno va a tener el
mismo valor absoluto que uno
pero tiene el signo opuesto el 1 es un
número positivo por lo cual el opuesto
va a ser un número negativo y para que
tenga el mismo valor absoluto tiene que
ser menos 1 y listo
menos 1 las dos formas de pensarlo están
súper bien